se encargan de atender a las víctimas de
bombardeos cuando un misil impacta en su
distrito tienen segundos para salir
corriendo a ayudar
julia tiene 27 años y está al mando ella
decide cada movimiento
si el miembro de alto rango es quien
toma la decisión y una ambulancia va a
un ataque grande y se necesitan más
coches es el primero en llegar el que se
queda hasta el final hasta el último
paciente tenemos una clasificación de
pacientes así que vemos quién necesita
ayuda urgente y el primer equipo hace
primeros auxilios y llama a otros coches
en un ambiente hostil como este es
fundamental trabajar en equipo en
aquella este mar efe tv es una escuela
julia desde hace mucho tiempo y por fin
trabajamos juntos para mí esta es mi
pequeña segunda familia
es inevitable preguntarles por el miedo
a un segundo bombardeo que hiciera que
ellos los primeros en llegar al lugar
también sean alcanzados por la metralla
el miedo se queda en un segundo plano
porque entendemos que alguien necesita
más ayuda nosotros estamos bien cuando
oyes explosiones encima de tu cabeza
tienes miedo un segundo pero luego
mantienes el control y sigues trabajando
capta caótico es transparente no
son las 12 de la mañana y mientras
esperamos
varios misiles sobrevuela en la central
de paramédicos que acabamos de recibir
una alerta y han disparado contra un
parque uno de los parques más
importantes aquí en heart
en menos de 10 minutos llegamos al
parque
[Música]
proyección
de fondo retumba la artillería esta
mujer ha resultado herida después de que
un misil impactara cuando paseaba con
sus dos hijos y su marido tiene dañados
los pulmones
los paramédicos se juegan la vida a
diario en esta guerra de ucrania yulia
valer y julien y vuelven al centro de
mando y repasan las alertas todavía les
quedan horas de trabajo por delante y
están en la primera línea del fuego